paroled to the corner Ensminger last
year did some things but joe brady
coming on as the passing game
coordinator totally different offense
burrows got time and he's
before receiver look the inside pass
fill another weapon for Joe boro boro
not pressured much today he go right
before the student section too
[Applause]
bad time pickup of a cane girl right
back at it
Thursday
Joe burrow into the endzone touchdown
LSU Terrace Marshall
[Applause]
[Applause]
Burrell a man in zone it gets sure
anything Burrell keeps it
[Applause]
Damon's drop back Burrell China thread
the needle
[Applause]
team right now as you see no running
back in the backfield and a touch sack
pair of SEC teammates over the last 20
seasons with at least five touchdowns in
the team's first four games
Jumeirah chase he's in a chase
yards per play add to that with his
touchdown Jets crunch Omar chase
and since the first quarter at Texas two
weeks ago this is going to be a big one
it's so much
borrowing from pole guys if him that's
been done Joe Burrell passes the cheap
shot into the end zone
burro right now pocket holds another end
zone shot beautiful Dixon catch this
joke near the red zone borough over the
middle passes caught touchdown
so we'll be at the half-yard line
borough will try to quarterback sneak it
in and does he get in no sign just yet
and there it is touchdown LSU whistle
net one on the zone read burrow to throw
going up top looking toward the end zone
Pass is caught Jamar chase touched
burrow scanning the field pressure comes
back across the middle touchdown the
play action for borough going up top
toward the end zone
Jefferson is there makes another catch
borough pass caught by Moss touchdown
pass number five the plain facts
burro's across a minute like he's
covered girl
[Applause]
fires a dark fog is it a touchdown
Jefferson was left
I have receiver look
steps up
fuchsia that has chased a
with yobbo
Thank You children
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
first of all of the age the patrols for
the touchdown
Jamar chase
[Music]
just in Jefferson 19 to change 29 to
chase it
[Music]
there are five blockers
we will
[Music]
June are chaste I think he's thinking
about his neck
twisted over
Pierce Marshall is gone touchdown LSU
sets up fires to the
words even wants to go with the ball to
majority of the time 22 year old
transfer from Ohio State eluded the Raj
what's it take for a touchdown
they'd here and ended up transferring to
Nebraska I had a chance to visit with
them today before they gave over at the
Grove
borrow throws Jamar chase now it's
possible he could be the number one pick
in the draft in the NFL next year Justin
Jefferson will win that race they're in
the red zone again comfortably so from
the seven borough touchdown
they bring pressure right in his face he
got it off Jamar chase breaks free
they have angles on him he made a great
cut to the outside one with Matias
Moscow the unsung hero in the
aforementioned
[Applause]
the air again gets where the pass and
time it's a play-action here for burl
with a ton of time wide open tonight
chase walks in some mesh routes and
cross routes involving those guys on
third and 10
seven minutes to go in the opening
quarter why doctor he said he wasn't
sure he wanted to put his family through
that
[Applause]
in a deep strike and an open receiver to
the Chasen of it
they bring a blitz is this the record
[Applause]
light clock down to three
just got away
time
scaling the field
[Applause]
now he's gonna go do
[Music]
there's the fake there's the lie
dopinder
quick slam their lives
call it touch that all over the field
someone up
the fade to the colander Jefferson
touchdown LSU